Um, and so three guys
go to confront Hamilton
on these charges.
One of the dudes was future
president James Monroe.
And they went, yo, Hamilton,
we know what you did,
you know what you did.
Check out these checks
to James Reynolds.
What's up?
And they accuse him
of embezzling funds.
And Hamilton goes,
no, no, no.
I was just [bleep] this lady,
and her husband
was hitting me up for money.
I didn't touch American money,
and I have all kinds of proof.
And he, like, vomits information
all over them.
Oh, wow, that was more
than we needed to hear.
And we're good, thanks.
The info about the affair
gets somehow miraculously
printed in the paper.
Hamilton is not a great dude.
I know you think he's great
'cause he's a war vet,
and he's
the Treasury Secretary,
but you're gonna learn the
truth real soon.
And Hamilton gets this
and he goes to James Monroe,
[whispering]
what the [bleep]?
Like, I told you that in
secret.
And James Monroe's like,
it wasn't secret
and it wasn't me.
Wasn't me who--who, uh,
published it.
Mother[bleep]!
I told three people
about this
and you're the one
who was taking notes,
so I know it came from you.
Like...fess up.
[bleep] you.
So Hamilton, over sharer,
writes the Reynolds Pamphlet.
The whole thing reads like
a Dear Penthouse letter.
Like, dear America,
I never thought this would
happen to me.
But one day,
this ripped bodice woman
showed up at my door,
saying,
oh, my husband's beating me,
left me alone
and I need money
and I need help.
You are a man of honor.
Can you help me?
Hamilton's like,
I could give her money
or I could [bleep] her
and either one would be
acceptable.
The--the Reynolds Pamphlet
is like Dick 101.
And, by the way,
he sent this to his friends.
Being like, hey,
I think I'm gonna publish this.
And everyone was like,
hey, bro, I don't think
this is a good idea
to publish this.
Like, maybe your wife
and your seven children
would not love it
if you published this.
And Hamilton's like,
well, I mean, like,
I got accused of embezzling.
And, like,
I can't let that stand.
Maybe the, like,
marital infidelity trumps that?
I know it doesn't
in your head,
but to everyone else
in the world it does.
Um, and he's like, no,
I can't let that shit stand.
And Hamilton goes back
to James Monroe
and--and now Hamilton's like,
well, it's all out in the open.
um, and if you still wanna
settle this,
because I know you're the one
who leaked it.
Um, Monroe's like,
well, I didn't leak it,
but if you wanna, like, fight,
like, let's do this.